Affairs am mounting in Lebanon of an
escalation in the fighting between
Hezbollah and the Israeli Army that
began after the start of the war on Gaza
more than 4,000 people have left their
homes and villages in the South Lebanese
officials say the country is already in
economic crisis and if there is an
allout War it would struggle to support
displaced people they could number more
than a million Ali hasham has more from
Southern
Lebanon the intensity of attacks on the
Lebanese Israeli border is increasing
hisbah has attacked several Israeli
military posts from Shah Farms towards
the E West in nakura and Al now Israel
has been shelling this borderline and
also today there were several attacks
you using drones one attack was close to
she where three hisbah Fighters were
killed when a drone attack on their car
and another hisbah fighter was killed in
hola when a drone targeted his car there
also so now the situation on the border
is escalating and actually we used to be
able to cross this line but now it's
becoming much more complicated with the
amount of shelling increasing many
people living in the villages on the on
the border decided to leave towards
safer cities such as T NAA or even to
Beirut now the concerns over the
situation in Lebanon sliding into the
bigger conflict is aming and we can see
the United States Secretary of State
Anthony blinkin calling lebanon's prime
minister and showing support as he as
was announced to the Lebanese people at
the same time warning of the possibility
of escalation hb's deputy secretary
General said that his party is part of
this battle and warned that the more
Israel is going to escalate his party is
going to be involved Ali Hashim Al jaaz
nakura South Lebanon